[Music]
last year at the 2017 Game Awards the
industry icon award was given to Carol
Shaw for her work in game development
and in celebration of International
Women's Day let's take a quick look at
Shaw's history with games and her
importance on the industry today
[Music]
born and raised in Palo Alto in 1955
Shaw grew up in a household filled with
technology her dad was a mechanical
engineer at Stanford and she spent much
of her childhood playing with model
trains building sets and anything that
stimulated her young mind she blossomed
into a gifted mathematician at an early
age and in high school eventually found
a love for computers as well she
attended the University of California
Berkeley for both her bachelor's and
master's degree in electrical
engineering and computer science
respectively and went straight to work
on video games right afterwards her
first employer Atari at Atari she worked
on several games for the 2600 including
polo video checkers 3d tic-tac-toe and
super breakout she quickly gained
notoriety in the company for being one
of the best programmers for the 6502
which was the processor that powered the
Atari console a few years later in 1982
she left Atari and joined Activision
where she eventually made her first solo
game for the 2600 River raid river raid
was a top-down airplane combat game that
was among some of the first
shoot-'em-ups and was a precursor for
games like twinby and ridin you would
steer a fighter ship down a river
shooting enemy tankers helicopters and
other jets for points River raid ended
up being a huge hit for Activision
selling over a million copies it also
received praise from critics across the
board and garnered a couple of awards
for best action game the game even found
itself as the first title banned by
Germany's federal department for media
harmful to young persons due to its
quote military content but apart from
its accolades and international
restrictions River raid was also a
landmark for female game developers
despite early computer programming being
a mostly female profession in the late
60s it eventually became a
male-dominated field when the home video
game console rolled around and before
Shaw there weren't very many female game
designers let alone ones that would go
on to create best-selling titles the
late 70s was a period where the industry
was still gaining its footing and people
like Donna Bailey who created centipede
and Carla Minsky one of Shaw's
coworkers were few and far between it
was rare that companies like Atari would
hire or even be able to find someone
with the talent and expertise that Carol
Shaw had although Shaw retired in 1990
her influence has radiated out to all
parts of the industry and has inspired
many woman over the decades to pursue
careers in game development
notable icons such as Roberta Williams
Amy Hennig Bonnie Ross and countless
others Oh at least a little bit - Carol
Shaw not just for breaking ground among
female game developers but also for
bringing women in the industry out of
the shadows of her male colleagues and
into the spotlight
[Music]